corriendo, saltando y bailando.
Me encanta bailar.
Sin embargo, con veintitantos
empecé a sufrir una serie de caídas inexplicables.
Y unos años más tarde,
me diagnosticaron una enfermedad genética recesiva
llamada miositis por cuerpos de inclusión
o MCI.
Es una enfermedad degenerativa de los músculos
que afecta a todos los músculos, desde la cabeza hasta los pies.
La MCI es muy poco frecuente.
En EE. UU. hay menos de 200 personas diagnosticadas.
A día de hoy, no hay tratamiento efectivo o cura,
y a los 10 o 15 años de su inicio,
la MCI normalmente lleva a la tetraplejia,
razón por la cual uso una silla de ruedas.
Cuando me la diagnosticaron, todo cambió.
Fue una noticia terrible
porque no estaba familiarizada con enfermedades crónicas o minusvalías.
No sabía cómo la enfermedad iba a continuar.
Pero lo más desalentador
era escuchar los consejos de otros
que ponían límites a mis sueños y ambiciones,
o me animaban a cambiar las expectativas de lo que esperaba de la vida.
"Deberías dejar tu carrera internacional".
"Nadie se casará contigo en tu estado".
"Sería egoísta por tu parte tener hijos".
El hecho de que alguien que no fuera yo
pusiera límites a mis sueños y aspiraciones
era ridículo
e inaceptable.
Así que los ignoré.
(Aclamaciones) (Aplausos)
Me casé.
Decidí por mí misma no tener hijos.
Continué mi carrera en Naciones Unidas
tras mi diagnóstico
yendo a trabajar durante dos años a Angola,
un país que empezaba a recuperarse tras 27 años de guerra civil.
Aunque no fue hasta cinco años más tarde
que anuncié mi enfermedad a mi jefe.
Tenía miedo
de que pusieran en duda mi capacidad de gestión y por ello, perder mi trabajo.
Trabajaba en países donde la polio era habitual
así que, cuando oía a alguien decir
que pensaban que había sobrevivido a la polio,
pensaba que mi secreto estaba a salvo.
Nadie me preguntó por qué cojeaba.
Así que no dí explicaciones.
Tardé diez años
en asimilar la gravedad de la MCI.
Hasta las tareas y trabajos más sencillos eran cada vez más complicados.
Aún así, continué con mi sueño de trabajar alrededor del mundo,
y me asignaron un puesto de ayuda a minusválidos
para UNICEF en Haití
donde estuve dos años tras el devastador terremoto del 2010.
Después mi trabajo me trajo a EE. UU.
Y, aunque mi enfermedad progresó considerablemente
y necesitaba aparatos ortopédicos y andador para desplazarme,
ansiaba tener aventuras.
Esta vez
empecé a soñar con una gran aventura al aire libre.
Y, ¿qué es más grande que el Gran Cañón?
¿Sabían que de cada cinco millones de personas que visitan el Rim
tan solo el 1 % baja hasta la base del cañón?
Quería formar parte de ese 1 %.
Lo único...
(Aplausos)
Lo único es que el Gran Cañón no es precisamente accesible.
Iba a necesitar algo de ayuda
para bajar los 1500 metros de descenso por terreno vertical irregular.
Eso sí, cuando me enfrento a los obstáculos,
el miedo no siempre aparece de inmediato
porque doy por sentado que, de una u otra manera,
lo superaré.
Así que pensé:
si no puedo bajar andando,
aprenderé a montar a caballo.
Y es lo que hice.
Y con dicha decisión tomada en firme,
empezó un compromiso de cuatro años
en el que alternaba miedo y valor
para emprender un viaje de 12 días.
Cuatro días a caballo para ir de una punta del Gran Cañón a la otra,
y ocho días de rafting para recorrer los 240 km del Río Colorado,
todo ello junto a un equipo de rodaje.
Alerta de spoiler: lo conseguimos.
Pero no sin enseñarme cómo mis miedos más profundos
podían crear una respuesta reflejo de un grado de valentía equivalente.
El 13 de abril del 2018,
sentada a dos metros y medio
sobre un caballo Mustang llamado Sheriff,
mi primera impresión del Gran Cañón
fue de conmoción y de miedo.
Quién podía imaginar que tenía miedo a las alturas.
(Risas)
Pero ahora no podía abandonar.
Reuní hasta la última pizca de valor que había en mí
para evitar que el miedo se apoderara de lo mejor de mí misma.
Embarcados en el South Rim,
lo único que podía hacer para mantenerme tranquila
era respirar profundamente, mirar las nubes
y concentrarme en las voces de mi equipo.
Pero entonces, durante la primera hora, ocurrió el desastre.
Incapaz de mantenerme erguida en la silla,
cuando descendíamos un escalón enorme,
me deslicé y me golpeé la cara contra la cabeza del caballo.
Todo el mundo se asustó,
me dolía intensamente la cabeza,
pero el camino era demasiado estrecho para poder bajarme.
No fue hasta la mitad del recorrido, a unos 700 metros,
al menos dos horas después,
que pudimos parar, quitarme el casco
y ver el chichón del tamaño de un huevo que sobresalía en mi frente.
Con tanta planificación y materiales,
¿cómo es posible que no lleváramos una bolsa con hielo?
(Risas)
Por suerte para todos, la inflamación dio la cara,
y se manifestó en forma de dos maravillosos ojos morados
que es lo más apropiado para salir en un documental.
(Risas)
(Aplausos) (Aclamaciones)
No fue un viaje fácil ni tranquilo
aunque no fuera el objetivo.
Aunque me daba miedo volver a montarme,
lo hice.
Solo para descender a la base del cañón
tardamos 10 horas
y era el primer día de cuatro a caballo.
Luego fue el turno de los potentes rápidos.
El Río Colorado en el Gran Cañón
ofrece algunos de los rápidos más fuertes del país.
Para prepararnos en caso de vuelco
hicimos pruebas en tramos más fáciles.
Les puedo asegurar que no fue demasiado elegante.
(Risas)
Tomaba aire cuando no debía,
me atragantaba con el agua
y era incapaz de estabilizarme.
Sí, fue aterrador
pero también fantástico.
Cascadas, cañones resbaladizos
y rocas sólidas de 2000 millones de años
parecían cambiar de color conforme pasaba el día.
El Gran Cañón es naturaleza silvestre
digna de todos los elogios.
(Aplausos)
La expedición,
tanto la planificación como el viaje en sí mismo,
me mostró un grado de miedo que nunca antes había sentido.
Pero, lo más importante,
me mostró lo valiente que puedo llegar a ser.
Mi viaje al Gran Cañón no fue fácil.
No fue como si una amazonas
recorriera sin esfuerzo alguno su camino con un escenario épico de fondo.
Sino, yo llorando,
agotada y con los ojos morados.
Fue aterrador,
estresante,
excitante.
Con el viaje ya acabado,
es fácil no darle importancia a lo que conseguimos.
Sé que quiero volver a hacer el rafting.
Esta vez, los 445 kilómetros.
(Aplausos)
Pero también sé que nunca más haré la parte de montar a caballo.
(Risas)
Es demasiado peligroso.
Y este es mi objetivo.
No estoy aquí solo para enseñarles mi película.
Estoy aquí para recordarles
que la vida nos enseña
a encontrar el equilibrio entre el miedo y el valor.
Y a entender lo que es y lo que no es una buena idea.
(Risas)
La vida es de por sí aterradora,
por lo que para que nuestros sueños se cumplan, necesitamos ser valientes.
El enfrentarme a mis miedos
y encontrar el valor para superarlos,
ha hecho que mi vida sea extraordinaria.
Así que, vivan a lo grande
e intenten que su valor tenga más peso que su miedo.
Nunca se sabe hasta dónde pueden llegar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos) (Aclamaciones)